you think care plan kid has a chance
with canelo i mean
anything no i didn't think it could
happen
i mean i think and he's he's a friend of
ours
i hope he do good oh he's your friend
you're going to his funeral
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hotbox with mike tyson i am
your co-host triple c
aka henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson
and today we have a very special guest
baidu jack
world champion what's up everybody
uh obviously he manages jack and he's a
former world champion too in the
in the sport of kickboxing can we give
him
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so what's up talk to us about it man
how's the how's it been lately man we uh
you know unfortunately
we're watching showtime and the glitch
is in your fight bro i was trying to
watch your whole fight but i don't even
want if you want to blame showtime
but i i caught partials of your fight
dude which one
the i think it's
actually there's glitches throughout the
whole fight to be honest with you man i
am
did anybody tell you that no yeah i
heard that
tell me about the fight the fight so
i was supposed to fight john pascal a
rematch rematch right
i beat him the first time yes you did
and they they robbed me we were supposed
to fight
uh like over a year ago so i waited 18
months for the rematch
i fought on his show to stay busy fight
and
um he tested positive for four different
steroids
oh [ __ ] he broke the record yeah
he broke the regular steroids right yeah
epos oh all that stuff
ain't that something [ __ ] yeah a
week or or
and you still be there yeah it'll still
be disastrous
we suspected it the first fight we asked
for vada testing they didn't test us
and and then for the rematch we begged
them and they they finally agreed to
vada testing
and see what happened but i knew he was
i i believe it was on that stuff because
he was looking like that for too
[ __ ] long yeah you know even people
down in camp with him
they called us after listen this guy's
juiced to the gills and the first fight
the punishment that he took in the
second half of the fight i mean
he wouldn't have made it so this fight
you know we we
i hate to say we knew but we knew listen
why can't they
vacant his title well listen mike that's
what we wanted to do we wanted to
no here's the thing so i told leonard i
go we'll fight for the title this fight
let him strip him and we'll fight for
the title
he said well he's got the option to test
for a b sample so that they can
you know you got to go through that
given this guy so many breaks four
four but why are they giving them breaks
what's the deal what is your perspective
when they're giving them these breaks
i don't have to preach it to you you
know there's politics in boston
absolutely
you know there's politics in boxing and
without you know getting too much into
that even though we'd like to talk a
little [ __ ] on the show but you can't
you can't because
you're still working with these people
you know and you know
and they look and they're looking at you
right now there's politics
but when the show is on they're going to
watch yeah and you know
i'm blessed and that i've been put in a
position where i don't need anybody
you know we make our moves thank god you
know we have faith and we do things the
right way we always
you know cross our teeth dot our eyes
and make sure that we treat everybody's
respect and do everything
but that's not always the way that we're
treated and especially with this fight
thank god mayweather promotions enabled
this vada testing because he was dirty
and he was willing to take by dude if
that's the case what's up what's up with
logan palmer you guys don't think he was
awesome um
i heard they was actually training
together so they're
in puerto rico they were both in the
same camp in puerto rico boy that
doesn't mean that logan was on anything
it's just that's the exhibition fight
there's a little difference but the
thing is
we're pascal you're bad we are the same
we're the same age
but he's been pro a little longer he got
more mileage than me but
normally you don't get better with h
right you normally you don't get better
the more
you go down yeah i mean i don't care
where you are the older you get
the doubt but i have better divas i'm a
smarter boxer than him so and he's the
warrior take punishment and you can
and possibly be like be better with age
and and
you know he got better the last uh two
three years
mike mike you've seen you've seen you've
seen assault in the ring right
yeah yeah remember that was that that
fight with the panama lewis hall
i was at that fight it was 1984 duran
then duran won the title that night
he fought um what was his name um
barclay
iron bark iran barclay won the title
that night june 16th
what's your take on steroids or anything
that has to do with people
illegally putting something's in their
hands like listen
dick right i'm not against steroids and
none of that
stuff right because everybody's using it
right but it shouldn't be used in sports
where people
are physically fighting when you risk
your life you can die in the rain
it should be if you want to run faster
you want to swim faster
anything accept physical compen physical
confrontation so this should almost be
repercussion because i believe
actually i forget is no it's criminal
criminal it's criminal
you're going to hit a man that's
attempted murder but exactly i'm a
murderer
i
and billy collins i was at that fight he
did time
he did time yeah yeah for the load of
gloves yeah for the loading no not even
loaded gloves they took the padding out
of it
and when he shook his hand he felt his
knuckles his father when he said
he felt his knuckles through the gloves
the reason henry that i was so upset
during that fight was i took you know
badou would have knocked pascal out and
you know you can't guarantee i'm telling
you badu would have knocked pascal out
he would have regained re had the
redemption for his his his
controversial laws he would have been
the wba champion which means the next
fight
his money doubles triples quadruples
that part of it
was five percent of what i was angry
about 95
was this piece of [ __ ] was willing to
take badu away from his family
his livelihood his lifestyle his health
and strip them all for what
for a win he's a high-priced prostitute
and that's what angered me about the
whole thing
it didn't work out that way but imagine
if it if he hurt him that's what i'm
saying
is is he who's willing to do that for
what you know it's happened to me dude
actually tj dillashaw he tested positive
for our fight
you know what i'm saying how did you
feel that morning
six different you know what i mean five
different pieces i mean whatever like i
said
i was expecting it for the first fight
or even before before
we i fought him but that's uh in my
opinion only
that's an a-class felony it's an
attempted murder yeah
what's the difference or murder if he
dies yeah else is he committed suicide
afterwards
in 2019 it was like four or five that's
six boxes
that's what happened with billy collins
he committed suicide after that
yeah that's crazy did you see his face
you see how tough he is you see his face
after that fight
he was so depressed he killed himself so
we got an emotional replacement guy
so this dude that i fought he uh from
venezuela you fought him already
yeah yeah i fought him already sunday
you don't know him
dervin colina so yeah got him fight yeah
so he came in in a week's notice so and
uh he was supposed to fight
the week afterwards but he was not on my
level obviously yeah but you know what
if
and if if i remember the glit man you
guys [ __ ]
how much fighter was how much you right
now or
no when you fight you fight 175 yeah
but i want to uh i want to be a champion
in the third one that's cool universal
that's a different
i know cooper why don't you fight um
[ __ ] well
why don't you [ __ ] hey why can't he
fight i'm homeboy
who 168 pound champion
canelo yeah we'd love the canelo fight
that would why don't you i'd love the
canelo
i gotta cut off my leg one of the legs
to make 160. no
wait a second for that kind of money
we'll cut off his leg
right now he listened 195.
that one he fought after that 75. so
you're gonna be a 75
fight no it wouldn't be for you to go
down to 16. to be honest i want to move
up
but unless before now i have
a month vacation after that if
if we get a huge opportunity for
something like that with canelo yeah
i'll find another fighter one second but
if not
why don't you ask for it yeah but he won
a unified
be undisputed at 168. and he was
supposed to fight kayla plant
in september right he killed it i
thought he fought him all right
and i i believe caleb's gonna block you
you know caleb
ain't laughing yeah he's gonna outbox
canelo alvarez mike
no maybe the first couple rounds
maybe for 12 rounds canelo canelo was
going to get outboxed by caleb plant i
said it on hot boxes
i saw this guy fighting he's going to
give you guys mike mike he's smooth but
he doesn't he doesn't have power
the only thing he don't have experience
he's going to get clocked
i mean
[Laughter]
but i believe he got the the right style
though look at that
pretty he's white he can box
he looks like from floyd mayweather look
at it look at him slick oh
slick slick wait till that [ __ ]
start hitting that body yeah
can i tell you guys the biggest threat i
think just look at him fighting i want
to see him
like this uh look at this [ __ ]
yeah 168 yeah mike look how slick mike
look how slick he is oh he's going to
get [ __ ]
up he's the one thing yeah yeah you
can't compare with all those opponents
that's the thing but he got the skills
but he just got got more experience i
think he needed
can i say something about that i feel
like he still has a lot of
a lot of amateur like there's people
that have that thump you know what i'm
saying canelo has that [ __ ]
thump i know this you know what caleb's
got what a lot of guys don't caleb
buried his daughter when she was two
years old yeah
he's got that killer attitude work
respect that anything's possible but i'm
telling you man
okay well can we look up our david
benavidez can we look him up
you you are why don't he fight better
feed it
that that's they don't like each other
that would be a great fight
that should happen they they uh they
actually had a little scuffle inside
better be this in the gym yeah that's i
think that's his first thing
is long strong super technical yeah he's
big super
mexican he's got finesse mic
now he's just like he's a beast yeah
he's a killer he ain't got no
finesse though caleb got the finesse he
got the just the power
[Music]
this dude right here is this guy
he's got everything dude that benefit
well
he is he's strong yeah but again caleb
out boxes both of these guys
oh we got sequel caitlyn this is some
[ __ ]
caleb your white ass
again that's part of the marketability
oh yeah the complexion is white it's not
you're not used to seeing somebody like
that
well he got the complexion for the
protection but he's gonna be in some
[ __ ] with this mexican
no jackfruit henry caleb is going to
outbox
all right listen canelo let's put in
canelo's last fight
wait wait but but you're you're ever
you're you're measuring them with with
billy joel saunders
yeah but he's also a good fighter though
oh billy joel he's the olympian he's a
two
two division world champion he's gonna
beat him stan this could be caleb be
honest no
no okay no so so the thing that canelo's
gonna possess with power billy joe
doesn't have power he's slick he can
move
he's actually like a 54 pounder
naturally he's a smaller guy yeah so no
canelo
i know about uh caleb he'd be considered
short for your guys as his weight class
t-rex super he's like five nine
five but i do want a world title at 168.
he was i had his title
yeah i know but you know this is that
money right here yeah yeah this is the
money
it's your retirement but i'm not going
to wait two three years just to not move
up just because
who's that cruiserweight there's nobody
really but i i don't know
i don't like to cut wait what are the
europeans up there they're all the
russians europe
as an african guy and i got the macabre
he got the wbc
who have been i don't even know who got
the other there's never been money in
cruiserweight you know
not until
you say he's a two-time olympian i don't
know he went to
i was like my olympia our olympics 2008.
yeah speaking about that did you know
he's an olympian
i have no idea we're from sweden no from
gambia my dad's
uh fought for gambian dual citizens yeah
yeah well i got it just for the
olympics jack why don't you tell us a
little bit about your story man cause i
imagine
obviously in sweden bro you got you got
blue eyes and blonde hair bro you know
what i'm saying like
that's what you think we got everything
in arabic african sweet right
yeah grew up i grew up i was born in
sweden muslims in sweden a lot of
muslims
yes in sweden in denmark as well
yeah yeah yeah you know the muslims they
migrate
yeah everywhere so did your parents
migrate to sweden when you're you're
so you're a bonus when your parents
migraines my mom is actually sweetie my
mom was white
and my dad is uh from gambia west africa
yeah so they met
in sweden so best of both worlds so i
got my
mental toughness for my mom my
physical strength my dad how was how was
your how was your ugh bringing coming up
in uh in sweden
no i had a pretty good upbringing he was
never rich but
uh i but the government takes care of
everybody
yeah it's like a middle-class society so
yeah i i didn't have it bad
i had it good i had a good but i was
never rich
or nothing but i wasn't uh you know
the best kid but i wasn't criminal i
didn't have any money
right i wasn't raised rich yet
no no you you're born rich other things
yeah
no you're born rich yeah because i mean
think about the money you work hard then
you get some money
right right one of one of eight siblings
really right one of eight i have still i
wish i had always liked a lot i won
that's why i have seven kids i always
wanted to have a big
family yeah i got two that's it one one
boy one girl that's it
always wanted a big family how are your
kids man what are uh boy girl
uh my girl melania she's uh five
malik is he's three oh young dad crazy
what they like to do
they like to fight they like to they
like to fight
three years old my daughter started
playing tennis and now she's like um
she's pretty good number three in the
country oh my god
oh my god they got a fluorescent eyes
bro yeah that's that's the trick man can
we get a close-up here man you guys
what do you got my wife is from iraq
where's the babies at
let's show mike with my kid oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you look like your mama and your
wife they don't look like you dude
[ __ ] they're never going to get pulled
over and [ __ ] never mind
[Laughter]
white kids ain't white
no they even were they they they're
arabs and they're black
and they're white i know this one i
regret he went to um
he created what i think i think he
graduated from
harvard at 12 or something his father
mother the average the black
he's blind eyed blue blonde eye
um blonde hair blue eyes white as a
[ __ ]
you know you never know what you're
gonna get baby right right
how did your how did you spark how did
you find boxing bro how did you how did
that whole love come about
oh i mean i always uh you know love
fighting watching him
how old were you when you started when i
started i was eighteen so i started
pushing like
a year later okay you remember watching
you remember watching mike when you're a
kid
i remember booking and that's late i'm
trying to think buster douglas yeah
right but i was
like seven yeah around that time yeah
1990 right now yeah 99.7 years old
i remember that um so i always liked
fighting and and a friend
brought me to the gym and you're 18
years old yeah or
17 18 yeah i had my first fight like
right before my
18th birthday so you did the whole
amateur so how how many fights did you
take amateur 150
150 150 um yeah
i know guys got 300 400 yeah you know i
mean you see the russians they got
five and six yeah that's crazy
you're about to be 30 i'm about to be
38. what do you think 26
better yeah i'm 36. do you think
starting later in the sport of boxing is
better for you
do you think too many kids get hit in
the head too young
no listen right this is weird right
all the guys are very few but when
they're successful the guys like larry
holmes and those guys
marciano there's a few when they start
late
because they're more mature and stuff
they become great
very few of them started like the larry
home started what 21 yeah
he was titled 22 times and stuff like
that he started at what
18 21 he's the older guy you know what i
mean
yeah i tell pro when i was 25 26 i think
it all has to do with the desire to will
the spirit i've got to bring that stuff
up and what kind of lifestyle you have
outside the ring too
no but listen um once you you got to be
at the delight you have to be the champ
before you become the champ
you have to have the lifestyle of the of
the champ and
before you become the champ so you have
to be the champ before you become the
champion
i know it sounds weird but that's what
it is you have to be the champ
spiritually you have to be in before you
become them physically but then
but then again i do remember the other
trajectory remember i asked mike
i asked mike about aliyah says what made
what made muhammad ali so special never
forget what mike said he's like
he was different because he could take
so much freaking pain
you know what i'm saying like ali oh
he's paying them oh off the
hook and then i i went i went and i
watched the larry holmes documented with
him and all you know just like man ali
man ali took a lot of punishment and
sparring man that's how you get punished
for him from sparring now he's born
fights right he'll fight but listen our
league got this you got to kill him he
ain't going to quit
yeah angle quit physical pain that he
could tolerate yeah no but anyways
spirit you got to get emotional
spiritual
you go [ __ ] quick yeah so what's up
tell us about a little bit about a floyd
man i don't know if uh
you want to i don't know if this is
far-fetched if you want to credit him to
save your creativity
is that far-fetched no i mean uh yes i
am i'm a mushroom
fishing honestly in 2012
and 2012 um i was sparring with one of
the
the rel brothers i fought his brother
later yeah andre
i fought him i spot him floyd liked me
um
and after that he signed me the two
and then after that i think the that's
when he fought uh
miguel cotto 2012 yeah and then i think
i fought the week after that's when you
walked me to the ring
in the little texas station or whatever
it was yeah so he signed me again
beautifully
he believed in me
and what's your take uh i want to get
your two cents on that
so when i look at boxing and my line is
this is a business disguises a sport
it really is and and when you have an
asset or a commodity
because that's what fighters are to
promoters and two managers and just
that's how it works
um by the way that's why the ufc is
successful as they are
because they they're not disenfranchised
like boxing it's one sanctioning body
one
promoter that you don't have to know
about ufc
if you have a bad fighting and never see
you again
yeah it's got to be entertaining it's
got to be fun but they don't care if you
win or lose if it's the best if it's a
bad fight
you never see that guy again he's
probably an alaska fight in the ufc
see boxing's very unforgiving your
records mean a lot so when freud's 50-0
when he was you know 37-0
42-0 everybody wanted to see him lose
where the ufc it doesn't matter if
you're a 50 you know
you know a 50 percent uh a 500 fighter
um they keep everything in the best
fight the best and you said it they got
to be the best
when they fight some fighters that they
don't get paid you know because
they didn't control that so the best
half the fight see like you say
it's too um disenfranchised boxing so
they can't get the best to fight the
best yeah of course now how long it take
manny and floyd to fight
but you know what you know what i think
part of the problem is with boxing now
with the ufc's taking over because
i i think it's perfect to have different
promotions is they got four belts
if you just have one champion
everybody's gonna go out to that one
champion
it's way more than it's four major they
don't know why they have the belt
for more money championships like listen
stay at god
champion joe lose with champions for 20
well 22
titles 12 13 years that's cool but
imagine like how are you going to get
one
how all the type guys gonna get a chance
no one's gonna get a chance
what's even now they got four belts
everybody can get a chance and everybody
get paid and
in those four belts mike then you've got
the interim champ the regular champ the
super champ the franchise channel the
belt
and the goal yeah when people hit
championship they pay
i get that mike but you don't you think
they're taking away the purity
for somebody saying hey i'm the best yes
check it out
doesn't it bellator champions check this
out yeah but there you go
check this out i am the best but i have
no money
that's why it's a business and you've
got to cater it that way how many great
fighters couldn't make no money because
they weren't exciting they beat
everybody though
from from one to ten they beat everybody
they can't be beat but they stink they
make you go to sleep
like watching grass grow
but they're beating the greatest
fighters out there he just looks bad
but you got guys like you know that that
are just not marketable because in
boxing you got to market yourself also
where again that's why the business part
of it you got like a guy like like bud
crawford
who can fight his ass off and he was
great but you know he doesn't live
exactly yeah he's talking about you talk
about terence crawford yeah oh
phenomenal fighter but you know and even
bob aaron was saying i lose money on
this guy
and i'd rather you know i could have
built houses in palm springs or beverly
hills whatever he said
based on this guy so it's a business
they don't know how to um
promote him i i agree with them how to
showcase him
yeah right that's not his job that's his
promoter's job no it's his job too
yeah this is my the baddest man on the
planet that's my job
i say it so much the world believes it
yeah
you know that's what we did with badou
by the way is here he was you know
another world champion another fighter
under mayweather promotions what we did
is we took him to the middle east where
he's a muslim world champion and he
stands apart from everybody we started
promoting him in dubai and saudi arabia
and katharina
where he becomes very popular in that
region i think
the the key is not you know to pat
myself on the back but what you have to
do for a fighter when you do manage him
is take him to areas where he can be
somebody
he doesn't just blend in with every
other champion
objectively boxing the main objective
peep game to get a home
man if they get a hotel they sponsor you
they pay for your expenses um you're
their [ __ ] they give you evidence
you're pretty woman they give you every
[ __ ] thing
no i'm serious you're right this is all
my deals i tell them you treat me like
i'm the most beautiful woman in the
world i know you're telling them that
and you need that yeah i tell them that
treat me like the champions woman in the
world a champion should never spend his
money
especially when you're a champion well
listen you said they shouldn't they
should
not well listen i like to spin man
but not for your travel not for your
hotel not for all of those kind of
things
yeah mike i think he might have
overspent though it's okay
literally just a little bit game right
is never forgotten
try try hurting me yeah and mike mike
you always talk about
how how it's paid forward you know what
i mean absolutely but it's all love
it's all love what am i gonna do with
200 million dollar 300 million dollars
and my best friend don't have [ __ ] he
might be on welfare
what kind of person is that right
you know who who is that who am i i'm a
street cutter and who am i to have a
billion dollars
don't i don't care about earnings how
great i am but who am i
i have a billion dollars you know
no really really who am i to have a
billion dollars
and my friend of them that i believe
god blesses you in certain ways with
certain things and it's up to you to be
able i mean we have free will so it's up
to us to be able to decide
what we do but you know especially if
you
a human being what kind of humanity are
you
yeah they have all that money and
everybody around you have [ __ ]
that's what baidu started the badu jack
foundation he works a lot of refugees
with syrian palestinian gambian refugees
builds you know
helps build orphanages wells things like
that that's a responsibility
what did that love that's purpose bro
where did that come from
i mean i always uh this stuff like on
the low i don't like to talk about it
and and
then i was like yeah come on we can
raise so much more money and help more
kids
i mean if we like kind of you know start
a foundation
and and make it bigger we can make it
bigger and help more people i'll say
yeah
some of your exhibitions you can do your
exhibition and you still get paid and
you have organization like the hotel i'm
gonna
[ __ ] do the charity page and you just
did that what we did for the last
[ __ ]
that was just for charity the on the
undercard but when you got a hotel you
got like a hotel friend um backing you
up
and that's your franchise like mgm or
something like that
you don't think you say you don't spend
no money they don't take it out of your
money and
these promoters they do anything for you
it's coming out your money
of course right you know of course and i
mean look at they've got to make money
too i mean everybody has to that's why
you have to put yourself in a position
to promote yourself manage yourself and
just try to lock in those
deals that you can yourself absolutely
if not you know you're just going to be
another commodity another aspect
of their family listen brother the main
objective is to keep relationship with
hotel um ceos
have had relationships with them and
that um
then eventually you guys can work out a
deal where he could be a much
uh an attraction at that hotel yeah we
did a fight
badou jack promotions out in dubai at
the five palms jumeirah
and those guys got behind badoo we did
the first ever a pay-per-view
boxing kickboxing card out there and
they loved you i mean that's
those kickboxing too no well it's
somebody
he can kick but we uh you know so so
yeah
that's what it is it's just opening up
different ventures all over the world
and and that's what in finding those
partners
would you do that like a k-1 fight or
mma fight
they won't pay me enough money right
that's the exact reason why
they wouldn't pay enough money you know
what i do i do remember a long time ago
mike when uh when they brought you
when they brought you to the ring i
think it was for pride with bob zach
can we roll the tape on that mike tyson
oh that's right you guys want to fight
in the ring i remember
now was this stasia was over what kind
of drugs were he on though now he got
steroids little type
he's got muscles on muscles oh so he's
calling you off from there mike
look at mike oh [ __ ] somebody [ __ ] up
over here right somebody's really
incapacitated oh look go back look at
that beautiful you know back in the day
the cowboys
keep it rolling the guy was doing it
back in the day
wow that guy's still on the mat you guys
are talking [ __ ] he's still knocked out
you guys are fighting over top of a body
who knocked them out it's not something
we're fighting these guys
[Laughter]
but he dropped bob sapp first oh did he
oh yeah yeah i dropped a couple times is
he alive
yeah i remember the for the roy fight
yeah and then
that's business that has been beautiful
enough for him
love it nice i love him there he is he's
coming well you're pretty like
cosmic you look hostile look at this
look at this look at this
oh man it's a [ __ ] look how many [ __ ]
jumped in the ring
[Laughter]
mikey mike you look you look super light
there mike
oh man i'm so fat miss hiding it we got
our fatness good
as fighters well sapp's got to be what
like 350.
yeah he's a monster he's pretty tall too
right
so what would be the strategy i got
fifty thousand
points about his mob go home a hundred i
got around a hundred a hundred fifty
dollars to do this
can you believe this it's a business
disguise as a sport baby can you believe
this [ __ ]
wow so why why didn't the fight happen
um i don't know because um
so many people start asking so they went
like this they said um
it's probably a money thing no they
didn't they put out um who wants who do
you want mike to fight and they
roy was one holyfield was one linux was
one no i mean back then
here oh you were supposed to fight him
back then or no i don't know what [ __ ]
i was doing oh my god
i don't like it yeah i forgive my you're
actually you're
actually child you would have killed
this dude mike this is that
heart attack he can't breathe i mean
it's already been 10 minutes after the
fight he's still
uh that's what i'm asking is he alive
because this is like 20 years ago
he's on lots of good stuff now he's the
other guy
the kimbo slides yeah yeah when he died
yeah really i was at that fight and
where was that fight virginia i was
there when he died
he fought his bodyguard he died in the
ring
well he died at the hospital the way he
was look um
it was just really scary wow it was
really scary you seen them having a
heart attack right there
wow they i believe um
he was disposed once he went in the back
i believe he was
passed away before he hit the hospital i
believe
badou winning your first world title man
how was uh
you still remember those feelings man of
becoming a world champ for the first
time
yeah it wasn't that long ago six years
ago uh i mean it was
like i was finally and uh
after all the whole world the whole time
what happened when you went back to
sweden the world champion
oh i came with the belt in the airport
everybody
i don't know i'm crazy they said i was
the the greatest uh
swedish fighter since my johannes yeah
you're so much better yeah he's never
defending his ti it defended his time
against away passing he got knocked out
and yeah
but uh yeah but he's he's heavyweight
and he's
100 swedish yeah you know they're gonna
love it but
i don't i don't try to compare myself to
you can't compare yourself
to anyone else everybody else could
compare you right right yeah no that was
a huge thing back then um but
i stayed humble that was just the first
goal i wanted
a very humble brother yeah very humble i
want to become uh
because i'm a muslim that's why i'm
humble i take one moment
wants me to talk some [ __ ]
i can talk [ __ ] too though yeah but the
muslim world loves you no
no they know how to do this [ __ ] for
promotion
what's it like man being around uh you
know being around mike manning he's been
around me
yeah uh sometimes this is our family
thank you both friends him and uh
and roy was my favorite fighters growing
up and got i got to know that
what'd you think when they both fought
each other he knew he was gonna lose
i know it was gonna happen but right now
yeah but uh yeah when he walked me to
the ring the first
was that i think it was my first tv
fight in 2011 or 12.
yeah that was dope and uh yeah i mean uh
who hasn't been a fan of mike but listen
when i first met him a long time ago he
said i thought it said his name was
bojack
bojack's another great fighter from the
40s and the 50s
lightweight yeah lightwing i said man
you got a big name to live
up to and what about for you i'm here
watching watching your guide man grow
and
where he wants to go he's not finished
with him i know what you mean i've seen
you guys
got some more places to go yeah we've
gotta see his career blossoming
what do you expect you know what do you
see what do you foresee in him
in the future man obviously i know he
wants to break records he does and
and i mean the biggest thing with me is
our connection with badou is you know we
share the same faith and that was the
first thing that attracted me to working
with him was
how humble he was and how down to earth
he was and uh and being the fighter that
he was was just you know a very unique
kind of mixture is you know a good
muslim plus a great fighter um so we
started working by i've only been
working with badu for about five years
now
the 2017 is when we started and you know
we've done some great things
thank god outside of boxing with a
nutrition company with his foundation
with the baju jack promotions but you
know i i mean
badou wants to keep fighting i would
like him to start doing things outside
of boxing and start you know having
multiple sources of revenue and
he needs buildings he needs to get his
um podcast the problem is by dude i mean
we i
we we have we have a channel but dude is
just not a talk he like he
you know even like the whole youtube
thing you know we're getting making me
mad
i was i was talking a lot last week with
uh pascal
he's got a lot of great people behind
him we've got you know a team
called smart stop behind him now and you
know we're going to start doing a lot of
uh
things with badou so uh i'm very proud
of him continue
to be what he whatever he's not he has
to be
talking about business now mike mike
calls him numbers
ellie what you got what you got for us
man what stats you got first that's what
life is
right yeah life is about numbers just
name it you got a
birthday in your death date and then
between your phone numbers your inmate
numbers
everything's a number times the number
it's all wow i said mike we got the site
completed here ellie what you got what
you got first
numbers that's numbers hey hey numbers
numbers
call pastel somebody one of his
opponents carl who you fighting that
the guy he said i don't want to talk to
pascal he's cheating call somebody you
got pascal's number
call logan paul carlos yeah come on man
we're going to get here mike and i are
co-promoting that one
you win i'm in then they watch legends
only
you know what i get it bro i get it i
get you you know
when somebody does some [ __ ] like that
or something like that yeah we're done
with them
logan paul i mean come on no
it's a paid you're a prize fighter i
know i'll fight him but do you think he
want to fight me
no no listen oh you'll kill him you're
an entertainer
yeah you can't be a judgmental but oh
he's not good enough this is
entertainment
and this is going you're gonna take a
check home you'll go to hit your bank
he's gonna go to his bank
no i guess it's a wrap i'll be fighting
i bought eight world champions
back to back i deserve some easy money
but
the question is not gonna be easy
fighting [ __ ]
he's fighting
he's already the greatest fighter to
ever live
he was just playing and he was 50 pounds
lighter he's my size
well he's the only one that's why i
thought you would
might give him a good fight you know
this would be easy but
but i don't mind but hey logan call that
[ __ ] excuse me call mr logan's
manager please
but it's still you know
listen you don't give me eight that's
too much of a risk man hey this is what
i know
you gotta be more what's that word when
you're um crazy
no you just gotta have more beliefs man
make [ __ ] happen
yeah there's no but i think you can make
your own your realities happen i guess
whatever's in your mind you think what
happened listen no make it happen come
see me i would love
i would love that but but i don't i
don't mind
they got the balls to fight me he's
going to fight you he's
stupid enough he's going to fight you no
yeah stupid enough no listen don't say
that
he is stupid enough to do it
logan's got a good shot he just went
eight rounds with floyd yeah listen
that's what i'm saying confidence he
might he might hate three minute rounds
right listen i fought the best guy blah
blah blah
floyd you know he said well floyd fought
the best two that's what he said
ellie how would you describe his uh
badou jack's career man this
this guy's encyclopedia mike this dude
knows everything
incredible because people forget that he
had a fight where he didn't win he
actually got stopped
and everybody wrote him off you remember
that yeah people said you'll never fight
against the journeyman
yeah and then he came back and won the
title i've been with him in china we've
been uh
ukraine and people love them all over
the world yeah
very some of the greatest guys of all
time how would you describe
it if you were to describe in a couple
words man how what would it be as a
fighter
great great fighter very
quiet great person too
so we're getting a lot out of them right
now mike
halloween october 31st 1983
83 baby i was in the nationals
1783 so what's up are you gonna get a
monday or you uh don't
you're fumbling over there dude what are
you and that's not like you man
normally you had people on the phone
within seconds
are you been drinking are you trying to
get jeff on the phone
i don't believe he'll he would fight me
but if he
will i think if he is i think he would
and i think it would be a very
entertaining fight
i think he would too well what would you
say i'll tell you why because
he's in his early mid-twenties he's got
a lot to prove
with ksi you were with ksi the guy that
you trained to beat him
but why would it be entertaining that's
what i'm saying he's gonna be
entertaining because he's a big youtube
celebrity
actual fighter he'll come at you you're
gonna come right at me he won't come at
me he is
gonna come i'm gonna hug him floyd floyd
is 50 pounds floyd's so much smaller
than him he couldn't do anything but hug
him he was tripping and he was hugging
him yeah but with you he's gonna
never let a small guy uh like
back me up why do you stop talking us
out of the fight i know
okay he's trying to make you money from
yeah i'm just trying to say
but hey but i think he's i think he's a
bit i think he's a bit offended cause
he's right i'm like thinking dude how
you gonna put him against
he's going to kill him let's say
yesterday it's a good fight there's a
possibility that
he's going to go a few rounds and he did
really well in the floyd fight so it's a
possibility he can go a couple of rounds
with you but exciting rounds
me and floyd is almost the same age too
so maybe you're a little bit older i'm
all
i'm older this could be if logan paul
beats badou jack he will be go down pond
for pound one of the best fighters
in the history of the world in the
history of the world you're talking
about who
oh no doubt about it he'd be a great
white hope like a [ __ ] yeah he
beats ba dude
and mind you the thing is there's
animosity there because you know badou
was with ksi
he walked ksi out to their first fight
and he was in the camp with him
he walked me to the ring i walked ksi to
the ring did that fight
he improved that bro
yeah but there's different like even in
boxing too like five pounds is a big
difference
yeah you know what i'm saying like yeah
five pounds and there was probably 50
pounds yeah
for little guys five pounds is a big
deal but if he wouldn't
you know he was holding floyd the whole
time flood water probably stopped him
after floyd was gonna start with the
body punches yeah and then the floyd
stop
i thought but listen but you know what i
noticed those little punches that he
flew with i know they hurt they don't
look like they're everybody
hurt because he's 50 pounds heavier yeah
but the thing is arm punches
he he got bigger like a weight lifter
arm punches
but still but it's hurting 50 pounds
yeah he didn't like clean but yeah he
had pulled some good points before he
took some hard punches
yeah think about it too with logan paul
he's not a youtube guy this is a guy
that wrestled
four years in ohio which is one of the
toughest states for wrestling the
toughest yeah you know what i'm saying
like this is this is this is this is
in football ohio yeah you know what i'm
saying so it's not like he's it's not
like floyd
fought this real youtube disney kid like
no
yeah was logan a disney guy also no no
but they they go with it i roll with
youtube
i'm with you i'm gonna be disney
[Laughter]
what is your prediction if i fight him
listen all right listen you're gonna say
it again
what is your prediction about fighting
and that's what he asked me but i said
floyd's gonna knock you out [ __ ]
and i'm listening i think you'll knock
him out but then i said that about floyd
you never know mike one punch could
change everything and you know baidu is
getting a little bit older so you never
know
yeah this guy moves around he got
something
and he had energy even though he was
tired he was moving never stop moving
yeah i think the build up would be great
to it because he doing all the talking
you're too humble you just stay quiet
can i say something about that even even
being muslim you know the person that
made khabib
conor mcgregor yeah you know what i'm
saying it's actually the only fight i've
seen with khabib but that's but that's
exactly what i'm saying right mike
you find a villain man he you you be the
person that you are you need that
villain
you know he's promoting whatever i
always play i guess who i am
you know what i mean i'm the lovable
villain
i'm humble but i don't think no [ __ ]
like i could talk i could and i wouldn't
but
it's it's the exact same thing could be
but look at look at what could be become
he's become a mega
man yeah you get somebody like that you
drop somebody that's a villain
yeah you know what i'm saying i'm nuts
you know i'm i don't i'm until something
suck my [ __ ] dick
who was that reporter for the lennox uh
lewis pike
you said i will ask you like uh that
[ __ ] i don't know who the whole
reporter was that
i don't know some little that was ellie
[Laughter]
what did he yeah he said you're a
[ __ ] animal you need to be in a cave
oh you said that oh damn
animal [ __ ] white [ __ ]
yeah but my my mike you always got a
foot on that line you always got a foot
on that line yes
you're one step away from always going
off no that was the best
you gotta make the press conference ever
you have to let these guys respect you
have to let them know if you say
something's a possibility [ __ ] you
might be in the hospital i don't know if
you want to talk about you remember the
first time we met
and buffalo somewhere right yeah do you
remember that what happened in the hotel
room
tell me please
[Laughter]
it was 2013 and and we brought you out
to buffalo
2013 eight years ago and uh and we
brought out mike to do a big meet and
greet and then we brought him out to one
of our fights in in lockport new york
and uh
and and at the meet and greet before we
hyped this thing out we sold it out we
did we put out
when i say we hyped it up i mean we i
signed mike
to come out uh three months before we
did that and and what i in
and the problem is i went on vacation
with my wife we actually had our
honeymoon a week after so all through
the honeymoon that's all i'm doing is
working on promoting the fighting
so i mean i didn't really have much of a
of a honeymoon
so so we were promoting the event
promoting the event we sold it out we
had like
thousands of meet and greets sold pumped
it up all the new stations were covering
it first time mike tyson comes to
upstate new york
so he had a guy that was working with it
we're going to call him such and such
and such and such says to me hey
i'm representing mike you know we'll get
the deal done and he did he was the
middle guy that put us together i never
dealt directly with mike or kiki it was
always through this guy
and he told me the price is x amount and
i said okay and i said you know and then
there's there's deliverables on the side
what he charges you know for autographs
but he charges for pictures and we said
okay he goes the amount is this much
i go okay great but that's not what the
contract says
the contract says x and he goes listen
do me a favor i'll cross it off
i'll initial it i'll go yeah but mike's
contract doesn't say that
he goes listen i'll deal with mike don't
worry you know they take a long time to
fix the contract
and i go look i'm gonna sell i'm gonna
upsell the tickets based on your number
and he goes yeah i got you so we sold it
based on that number
mike flies in no the day before he like
flies in uh
ryan fitterman comes in and he goes all
right you know what's the deal i go we
got you know
900 meet and greets sold he's like holy
cow that's huge
and he goes and rates this i go no the
rate's this he goes who told you that
[Laughter]
no you know ryan's very militant well
who told you that i said
such and such he goes who's that i go
who's that like well the guy's got an at
mike tyson.com
email address and i've been talking to
him he's the one that got me the
contract
and he goes does mike know this i said
oh [ __ ] i go brother i i go ryan
i can't deal with it we got the events
the next day so
uh so he goes all right so kiki calls me
that night and she's like hey brother
how are you stoma
and she's like tell me about this so i
said this is what's going on she goes
oh no she goes mike's going to get
pissed if he finds out she goes i don't
know who he thinks he's messing with
you do me a favor don't tell mike until
he gets here i i've we've got too much
invested into this thing
she's like all right she says i'll tell
you what let ryan talk to him
by the grace of god mike's luggage got
delayed a little bit so mike was able to
sit when he landed to sit in the
in the car with ryan and he kind of
broke it all down with it so fareed and
i are sitting at baggage playing freeze
like i heard we got a little problem i
go free
this is the first time i met these guys
right i was like i don't want to get on
the wrong side of mike tyson
so we sit in the car
and man you know i'm very confident in
myself but what i didn't want to do was
lock eyes with him
so so so as soon as i looked up mike was
already fixated
on me he was just you know giving me
that look and i was like [ __ ]
and he goes brother amir come sit next
to me i was like oh
man either this shit's gonna go down bad
so he says tell me about yourself and i
go look mike there's good and bad let's
just
talk about betty because no no i just
want to hear the bad stuff about you
[Laughter]
i said mike can we just talk about the
business hand he goes no no don't worry
about that
we're going to take care of that when we
get to the hotel so we start talking we
get to the hotel of course there's a big
reception there everybody's taking
pictures of mike and he's
cool as a cucumber man everything is
good i had two off-duty police officers
on with us that i hired to stay with us
the whole day
and i look back and i go stay close just
stay close to me the whole time
so we go and mike says call such and
such to the room
i go okay so we go up to the suite
mike's sitting there of course you know
it says no smoking mike's smoking the
cigar
and just tapping it on the ground
all right who's gonna say anything to
mike tyson right so i'm sitting there
i'm like man
so as soon as you walk in the room
[Laughter]
so we go into the room and mike tells
the cops he goes stay the [ __ ] outside
and i'm like
no um part of me was like this shit's
gonna be amazing
and then part of me was terrified that
the event was gonna go crazy
yeah so the guy walks into the room and
he's walks like a little kid that just
did something wrong and
it's just me fareed ryan and mike and
then the guy walks into the room
and he wouldn't even look at mike it
might go sit right there
so then mike puts his wife on the phone
he says kiki you know what happened blah
blah blah they go through the whole
business thing
and the guy is like listen mike i'm
sorry what i was trying to do is this
and this and this
and mike says you double dipped you took
you know a fee from him and you took a
free from me
you tried to steal from me i'm telling
you the 1980 mike tyson came out and i'm
just sitting there like
holy [ __ ] like it was just you could
just listen did you slap the [ __ ] out of
him
it was worth it i wish he would have
slapped him i wish he would have slapped
him it would have been over
so it almost seemed like mike didn't
know what like he was like trembling
like he was just looking around like
looking for something
looking for something to do to the guy
so he goes here's what you're gonna do
you're gonna go to your bank right now
and you're gonna pull every penny out of
your account and you're going to bring
me the receipt and you're going to bring
it to me cash
and we're not leaving here until you do
that and i'm looking at my luck like
man we're downtown buffalo the place is
packed it's sold out
we got to move we got a schedule so i
said mike can we
go no no and mike says to me brother
we're not doing this by the quran and
the sunni we're doing it by my way today
so i said okay the guy goes he comes
back the guy had like two thousand
dollars like fifteen hundred dollars in
his name
and he brought back the receipt and mike
looks at it and he goes
oh no this is what's worse before he
went down there he goes so the guy goes
okay
i'll go freed please take the brother
down there go get the money and come
back
so the guy goes and mike says to him no
no no you go naked
and i was like come on he goes i want
you to strip and you go down there naked
and you i want you humiliated when you
go to the bank and i'm like
mike so i just stepped in and i go mike
so i said mike why don't we just let the
guy go get the money and come back
he's like all right all right we'll do
that so the guy goes gets the money
comes back
gives the money to mike and he goes mike
i messed up you know please forgive me
for what i did
and mike goes you're going to go get the
rest of the money to vegas
you're going to go right now so i go
mike his planes tomorrow he goes no no
his plane's now
and i go okay i got no problem let's
just get the guy out of here and i go
such and such go
to the airport get the money give it to
mike's wife i go mike we good to finish
with the event
he goes once he goes like okay good
there's a van downstairs i'm like no
he's walking to the airport
damn gotta leave me it was november and
he went and he squared up with me and he
squared up the mic but then i started
thinking about it
and mike said something to me well well
mike said he didn't have a flight
he booked that when he got to the
airport but mike said something to me
that i'd never forget and he said
everything i have i worked for but
everything i worked for i don't have
because of people like that
and that hit me so hard that you know
just in his life how much he's been
you know screwed over and i know but
noah's so cool about
it got more now than that
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened [ __ ]
look i gotta
look this is my show man that's that i'm
just know
100 million come on guys come on give it
up uncle my girl
that don't mean that but i got like 85
million people looking at him right
now wow we got numbers we got numbers
hey you better change your instrument
for numbers dude
hey brother everybody what's your name
milton hayden
coach miller how you doing brother
oh man it's all beautiful man we're on
the show it's nice seeing you too
but but we have a new challenge for you
i'm trying to do business i'm trying to
get logan rich
look the champ want to defend his title
against logan
what do you think what do you think
about that
not me bro jack
yeah man does logan want some of that
smoke really what he really wanted
yeah yeah how you doing i think logan
could get a [ __ ] a fight
see trying to look for excuses
say what
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
tyson want me to fight logan no he wants
he wants logan's got him
wait man
yeah i'm telling he just [ __ ] went
eight rounds with the greatest i don't
know why both jackpot do jack think he's
gonna kick his ass
we're looking to fight conor mcgregor
next oh that's a good one too
50
[ __ ] that [ __ ] nah [ __ ] get that get
that money from mcgregor then come get
this boot bottle jack [ __ ] yeah bother
jack
with you i see bet the house he don't
knock it it's good talking to you again
brother
thanks very much love man thank you
tell logan to call in all right time to
call in if he wants
talk [ __ ] the bow to the jack all right
brother
tell him to call ellie come to court
alley he ain't gonna fight mcgregor
why why why don't you want to fight
martin yeah but i don't know why don't
they want to fight somebody
okay what other guys are my size though
who else can we get him on um
he can fight the other brothers the
other brother jake paul the other guy in
the fight
fight another ufc guy are they big
enough for you yeah the other one
they're the same way oh that's what i'm
gonna be on the cruiser to fight on the
on on mike's card
would be a good fight who who the the
mma guy
that would be a beautiful fight tito
ortiz i could be under my next card too
wait are you doing this versus me yeah
yeah
exhibition [ __ ] man you got options
brother
you got options man you're young isn't
he like
little he's he's he's older but he's
he's about 230 pounds he's
he's he's a lot bigger you're fighting
200. yeah come on man
do it man yeah yeah joke
that's cool you think it's funny until
you get that check
right now i'm serious you're thinking
funny you hit that chick and say when's
the next fight
serious yeah when do i fight next
yeah mike mike what what advice you have
for for jack here what uh what what
advice you got for him
hey man he's doing the right thing but
now we um
we're in an era of entertainment so all
these youtube guys
they're doing a lot for boxing this is
social media era yeah
absolutely you can't do nothing about it
so it seems like you want him to go more
that route mike
well listen he can continue fighting but
he needs to do that too
i don't mind i don't mind but i was just
skeptic like
i don't believe he he will fight me
though that's the thing i'll fight him
after uh mcgregor he will he ain't gonna
fight mike
mcgregor's still fighting right
mcgregor's gonna fight him for that
money
i think mcgregor's not stupid at all
yeah but
didn't dan white say that they can't ufc
fighters can't if you're
under contract you can't listen listen
tyron still will you yes
yeah i know i'm actually i'm actually
trying to get a fight with uh with
garcia and right now
yeah apparently they want to fight me
because you know again what mike talks
about entertaining i'm a [ __ ] talking
you know at the end of the day i'm just
a competitor dude yeah
i get i get what he's talking about him
too
well him too man they can help you wait
how much you weigh
how about one 157. walk around or fight
me in shape
when i'm in shape i probably i'm
probably about 147. you fight at 47.
no no i fight at 25 and 35. oh that's
that's you can fight them now oh yeah
yeah
yeah if you get in shape you could fight
them but at 140. yeah tank i like so
young too
right 30. and i fought amateur i thought
i found the amateur suit number one pro
the unboxing but i think this is how we
make it fair and tell me if i'm wrong
mike
we just make the glove smaller because
it only takes one shot
and i feel like i i i'll give myself a
chance any of those dudes
eight ounces six hours i'm thinking more
like four
like a straight up ufc yeah cause then i
think it would be fair
what about bare knuckles
no savagery gloves we're gonna get
gloves eight four ounces
you keep talking about that check i'm
trying to i'm trying to dance
knuckle those guys fight but they'll get
big checks and they got a lot of
punishment
yeah they cut everything they break
their hand did you fight bad knuckle
that's why um in turn essentially like
the and 1800s
the first round they break their hands
and then they start wrestling
most of those first um like turner's in
when they first started fighting
they wrestled they slammed you down they
did that too that's the king's rule
wow you could wrestle too then um
the markers of queensberry taught us the
three-minute round of one-minute rest
and that's how it happened and his son
right oscar wilde
had a love affair with the marcus of
queensberry's son
and the marcus of queensberry had him
put the jail in the redding jail
remember he wrote about the railing the
reading jail
the marcus the clintons the guy that
made boxing the way we fight now yeah
his son was lovers of um oscar wilde
and the marcus of queensberry
i enjoy watching these guys young too
rico
rico uh bernhard yeah rico you know
known as the king of kickboxing
heavyweight champion got a great reign
going on right now but remember he
fought the sabbath
yeah that was a great fight i think they
fought a couple of times then we broke
his stuff
yeah we actually had him we had him on
mike remember he came out here actually
all of it was me
i love rico because a beautiful person
but
what message you got for all the fans
men out there
you got listen how many millions you got
listen
talk to these people brother do you talk
swedish you speak sweetie
no everybody everybody's free to speak
english so it's better to speak english
so but let me have a language before the
english [ __ ] they have swedish
yeah i knew they had a language no we
talk with our hands
um yeah i mean thanks everybody for
everybody's support
and uh yeah we still got a couple years
left
now they want me to get into this uh
social media boxing
i could do one or two fights like that i
don't mind easy money
but um i'm looking to become a three
division world champion
so i want to try to get a belt at
cruiserweight as well
super middleweight like heavyweight
cruiser heavyweights are too big but
cruising no no no listen listen never
put that in your mind no
maybe it could be true but don't say
that heavyweight is too big
in 2021 not now back in the 80s
they're six foot nine they're not too
big they're too tall
six foot nine i just believe i believe
um it's the size of somebody's desire
more important yeah
you got anything else man you want to
kick off your come on tell these people
what you're talking about dude well
we're uh
he wasn't even supposed to be on the
show but i can tell mike's got a lot of
love for you man you said sit down
i want you to be brother man thank you
brother that's a two-way street
we want him a part of our foundation
absolutely i want to
get you guys hooked up with some of this
business i'm doing and we'd love to it'd
be an honor thank you
the body jack foundation badou's slogan
is giving children across the global
fighting chance in life
he's going to be hitting the refugee
camps again after every fight he goes
there when he fought uh marcus brown
when he got that
cut there 132 stitches they told him not
to travel he said i already made you
know a commitment to the refugees he
left like two days after yeah he was in
the train he was in the refugee camp two
days later
32 stitches she said yeah inside and out
three layers
yeah three legs so it's just an honor to
be with him and of course mike's
presence always and you know the love is
two-way street and henry it's great to
meet you and be here and
just supporting badoo team badujak and
we've got some great things our new
initiative now is working with
abused children abused foster children
in the united states also we do so much
around the globe but now we're bringing
it back stateside also so
continue to work on that that's really
the best part of this whole thing and
you could do that listen like i said
with our
fight stuff and when our charity thing
not gonna even come out of your
pocket you know i mean thank you if
you're a fight with us
our stuff don't even come out of pocket
just oh
there you have it man there you have it
guys you guys just watched an episode of
hot box with mike tyson i'm your co-host
triple c
aka henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson
with the champ and brother amir we're
out of here
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you